hi I'm Jessica Clemons and welcome back
to New rockstars a few days ago we got
some new look images for Spider-Man
across the spider-verse a movie that I
bet we're all excited to see and these
images are breathtaking they're gorgeous
and the animation of comic book style
was so beloved in the first animated
movie I couldn't wait to see what they
would do for the second movie in an
interview with Empire producer Phil Lord
said the first film had one animation
style that dominates this movie this
movie has six so like the different
variations of comic book spideys that
we've seen in the different universes we
can expect to see those reflected in the
movie the first film spent a great deal
of time focusing on the little comic
book depiction so across the spider
verse personally for me should actually
make us feel like we're in the comic
book and celebrating the diverse Styles
let's take a look at those images and
see what we can decipher from them we
see a new image of Miles Morales and in
the distant foreground are his parents
Rio and Jefferson already setting the
vibe that they might be more distant in
this movie than the last one now I know
New York is cold but my boy is wearing
three layers good Lord look at all them
jackets regardless I love this image and
it tells a lot even in a concerned look
he's oozing more confidence than he was
in the first movie The worrisome look on
his parents face may also signify the
unfortunate common storyline that all
Spider-Man have once they realize they
have to put on the mask to protect those
that they love and start becoming more
distant because you know they're young
adults you know you go from being in
your family's life like 24 7 to just not
at all being less open and secretive
it's common for your parents to be
worried that's what I get from this
image the overlaying in the distant
background but the shallow depth of
field being miles is so nice I love the
way animators convey this throughout the
first movie as well giving it a sort of
glitchy 3d effect I love the
translations from camera work to
animation it's always so fun seeing how
they use it and in this case in this
incredible illustration work we see the
water tower the neighboring houses and
folks Gathering we don't know the
specific location but mine is the water
tower it's similar to May's neighborhood
in the first movie I don't want to
suspect anything bad is gonna happen but
these concerned Looks Could lead to
something along with on May we also have
an image of what I think a spider Gwen
some people think this is Spider-Man but
I think from the hood you can tell it's
spider Gwen and between the two images
you can already deduce the different art
styles that's to come there are times
when I'm up so late that Cycles back to
early and I have a hard time sleeping
with Rosy finger Dawn creeping into my
bedroom it used to be the case that when
that would happen I'd grab a blue blocks
blackout sleep mask but now blue blocks
has become Bond charge so I grab a bond
charge sleep mask instead I know it
sounds weird to say I'm bad at sleeping
but I am maybe I have very thin eyelids
or something and I know I do look at
them
but if I'm using Bond charges sleep mask
that doesn't matter it blocks out 100 of
incoming light it's very soft it has
adjustable eye cups and an adjustable
strap for the perfect fit it works for
belly side and back sleepers and you all
know I sleep on my head put on masks oh
[ __ ]
oh I feel like a bat they are very
comfortable they're very soft and my
only fear is ghosts but sometimes living
with ghosts is a good thing this is the
way to make sure people don't cheat in
pinatas it's just complete darkness it's
super comfortable and I can already
confirm that I can see absolutely
nothing it is definitely Pitch Black in
here if you like sleeping in nothing but
Darkness these are actually perfect for
you launcher ships worldwide and have
great products like low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and blue light
glasses bomb charge is currently having
a boxing day sale with a massive 25 off
Statewide until January 2nd that's eight
days before my birthday just remember
that just go to boncharge.com and choose
your favorite wellness products and the
discount code will be automatically
applied at checkout bondcharge.com and
the 25 discount code will automatically
be applied at checkout look at it from
this is the side scary yes hello Clarice
now in the same Empire interview
producer Christopher Mills brings up a
huge chunk of art style details he says
this in reference to Across the spider
versus First Look trailer the two that
you saw in the teaser trailer were
what's called Earth
50101 which we're calling mumbatin
that's based on an Indian comic book
look and Nueva York from Spider-Man
2099's world that's based on Sid Mead's
style illustrations of what the future
might look like so mumbatin which I love
because it's Mumbai and Manhattan oh I
love it it's already gorgeous and the
art feels like contemporary
illustrations I love the look of these
harsh lines but the colors no matter how
vibrant mild or pastel blend together it
actually reminds me of spider Gwen
2019's cover art and Nueva York which is
928 AK Miguel O'Hara's Homeworld but
seeing as Miller said this is 20.99 we
could be seeing the 2099 storyline where
alcamax is taking over and maybe we'll
get more Doc Ock live either way the
animation looks super futuristic though
I love Miguel's animation it's still
kind of Blobby can you tell I don't know
how to draw it has no real black
outlines and when he's in motion the
color spills behind him like wet paint
the style is 100 Sydney though who
created a lot of neo-futuristic work the
car is the cylinder-like tunnel it
completely feels like a Blade Runner
fever dream Chris goes on play more he
says this there's also Gwen's World
which is earth65 and that was a
watercolor wash style that's reminiscent
of the covers of her comic books which
is very true now I love this still we
got from the movie because it's so
solemn the big white eyes with what I
think is glass brain down beside her
face I don't want this to be the look of
seeing another friend passing and going
witnessing but it just might be it does
resemble the cover to Gwen's comic books
the Allure of watercolor comes with
great use it's the accidents that come
out of watercolor pieces that allow the
artist to dive deeper into the piece but
also tell more about the piece that
acrylic and oil paintings in my opinion
just can't really do so using this
free-flowing Illuminating style for
someone like spider Gwen is nice to see
when she has sort of a shell around her
at all times but sort of stands out
around everyone else we also know we'll
be seeing spot and from the animation
images kind of resembled Miguel's where
there's no hard black lines just grayish
outlined ones Daniel Kalua will be
joining as hobby AKA spider punk I hope
his art comes off more rigid and hard
darker tones and match some of the comic
books but also to reflect the punk rock
Anarchist we also know Issa Rae will be
appearing as Jessica Drew AKA Spider
Woman I genuinely wonder what her
Universe could look like Bill Lord and
Chris Miller at Cinema con 2022 also
said there would be 240 characters six
universes and 1 000 people working on it
six universes six animation styles that
makes sense to make each Universe look
more different than the last each has to
have a different flavor let me know in
the comments what your thoughts are on
the new looks for across the spider
verse I'll be waiting non-patiently for
this movie to drop I love how much
you're taking into account the different
universes and how to wow us this time
remember this movie is part one and
there's still part two on the way and
maybe we'll see 100 more universes let's
hope follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at Lulu underscore Clemons follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching nevertheless
[Music]
some things just can't lose we're gonna
get demonetized
[Music]